that kids here today are so inspired by
you who are you inspired by honestly I
mean the kids that are here today you
know this is our future and it's so
amazing that they're here and that they
volunteered their hours to get a seat
here um it's incredible and just being
able to see where they're going to go
from this it takes one person to make
have that ripple effect and that's what
this event is all about need to talk
quickly about Pretty Little Liars
what kind of hurdles is ad going to put
in front of Emily for the remainder of
the season we also the last episode you
know there is a game that is now
involved and it's uh it's not gonna be a
fun one for the girls
it'd be fun for us to watch but not for
the girls what about Emma Center we're
gonna find out who the father of Ali's
baby is a hundred percent I honestly
think that this season everybody's
questions no matter what they were
except for the moms and how they got out
of the basement that will never be
answered but everything else we will
find out in this last what each episode
what answer aside from who ad is do you
are you excited for fans to get I mean
just like the shippers I want them to
find out who their favorite you know
couples will they last will they not who
is Emily gonna end up with that's always
a big big question so you'll find that
out the chance of it being ally I mean
yeah that's what everybody wants but
does that always happen in Rosewood I'm
not all the time no unfortunately what
was your reaction to finding out who ad
but like our writers are complete
geniuses and I would expect nothing less
I mean they completely blew it away and
I can't wait for this to be over only so
bad I don't have to hold my tongue every
single time I get asked a question about
ad I'm just like don't don't don't say
too much is your chance it's one of the
liars you speak to that I mean yeah you
never know I'm
ha
[Music]